auf geht's nach frankfurt
ich bin geil im fischer verlag in
frankfurt angekommen ich hoffe das passt
irgendwie von der belichtung und vom
thron befinde mich gerade hier in
irgendeinem büro und zwar machen wir ja
ein buch wie ich das schon sehr oft
erwähnt hatte deswegen bin ich einfach
mal nach frankfurt gefahren wo wir jetzt
ein wenig reden werden über das buch
über die themen ob ich eventuell noch
ein video sogar ein parcours so ein
exklusives video da ist übrigens max
aber hallo an alle so laut kann ich
klatschen das war es jetzt hier mit dem
meeting hat wahrscheinlich gerade in
welche zeit labs teils mäßig oder so
gesehen
wir sind jetzt durch und haben jetzt
alles mögliche gesprochen was irgendwie
mit dem buch zu tun hat ihr werdet das
wahrscheinlich in zukunft dann auch
alles mitkriegen inwiefern das ganze
auch euch betreffen wird sage ich mal so
youtube trailer irgendwie sowas mal
schauen eventuell ich das gar nicht wie
viel ich darüber was sagen da jedenfalls
kann ich auf jeden fall schonmal
kommunizieren dass wenn das buch draußen
ist relativ zeiten auch eine
fantreffen autogrammstunde signierstunde
in köln sein wird in der mayerschen da
ist es dann möglich dass ihr foto mit
mir machen könnt ich mir euer buch was
ihr da auch kaufen könnt oder schreiber
auf euer t shirt oder auf eur spielen
oder was auch immer ihr wollt also ich
bin da recht offen ist alles kostenlos
sie könnte einfach hinkommen des
samstages ein wunderschöner tag genauer
termin genaue daten sag ich euch dann
noch wenn ihr da bock drauf habe das
einfach nur das schon mal kurz es war
halt eines der vielen events die wir
besprochen hatten der signierstunde
seiner vorstellung sonst werde ich jetzt
noch mal durch dem fischer verlag
durchlaufen zusammen mit max hallo wachs
hallo sagt mal hallo an alle und da
zeige ich euch mal wie das ganze hier
überhaupt aussieht wie das abläuft
unserem verlagshaus mitten im bank tower
auf frankfurt schaut euch mal diese
landkarte hier vorne und zwar ist das
keine normale karte die man sonst
irgendwo sieht sondern das ist wirklich
das europa diesmal ganz links ist und
nicht sonst so hier in der mittleren ja
total gewundert ich dachte erst mal
irgendwie andere welt aber es ist
tatsächlich unsere welt und wir laufen
jetzt durch den fischer verlag und
vielleicht können wir da irgendwo das
ein oder andere klauen
zur freude wir sind jetzt hier auf dem
dachgeschoss angekommen von fischer
verlag das ist natürlich kein riesiges
bankgebäude sie mir sich das vorstellt
in frankfurt wo alles so richtig riesig
ist wohl eher war aber dafür haben wir
dort hinten die skyline da als der
commerzbank tower wir haben hier noch
kennst du die genauen namen von allen
banken das heißt der fernsehturm dieser
schmale spargel der erlös dieses ok go
ressort 5000 oder 7000 meter eso 7000 ok
bestätigt hatte ist das dorthin
die ezb die europäische zentralbank den
leitzins festlegt und auch wegen der
ganzen griechenland krise derzeit mitten
in der diskussion stehe dem dritten
hilfspaket und den forderungen und die
ganze scheiße habe ich einmal was sucht
oder gebaut und dass ich davon halte wir
stehen jetzt auf jeden fall gerade auf
der dachterrasse von fischer flack und
das ist schon richtig cool das ist alles
so macht man die skyline und sonst ist
auf jeden fall alles ganz cool gewesen
hier ich werde mich auch jetzt gleich
schon irgendwann mal wieder auf den
rückweg gegeben also es war ich wirklich
nur ein kurzer aufenthalt hier um kurze
sachen durchzusprechen und das buch ist
es ipcom hallo
so fand ich habe jetzt gerade noch ein
video aufgenommen das exklusive nur im
buch zu sehen sein wie ihr da gibt es
halt auch halt neben den fix wie schon
gesagt das dove axe drin sein werden
natürlich schon videos waren allerdings
auch ganz viele die noch nicht im videos
waren und command sie schon im videos
waren allerdings auch welche die nicht
in videos waren und so weiter und sofort
gibt es dort auch ein spezielles video
von mir wo ich was lava und was nur im
buch ist und ihr nicht zu sehen bekommt
wahrscheinlich das habe ich gerade
aufgenommen aber ich schau jetzt mal was
jetzt noch passiert ja freunde das war's
jetzt beim fischer verlag wir haben
jetzt alles erledigt was das buch angeht
ich lauf hier zum bahnhof und fahrer
wieder zu
der lange fahrt habe ich vor mir jetzt
ist hier gerade schatten aber man sieht
mich einfach gar nicht mehr jedenfalls
auf ich jetzt zurück und wir sehen uns
dann im zug oder so wieder
ja heute das war's jetzt hier vom blog
ich bin wieder zu hause es ist gerade
irgendwie so 20 uhr ich weiß noch was
essen und so weiter und so fort und
jetzt werde ich etwas cooles aufnehmen
davon werdet ihr dann allerdings noch
später irgendwann erfahren
dieser flop wird wahrscheinlich
hochgeladen worden sein am sonntag wenn
ich das alles hingekriegt habe es war
ein sehr kurzer blog ich habe wirklich
nicht so viel heute lebt ich war
wirklich in frankfurt wir haben sehr
sehr viele meetings gehabt und selbst
viel geredet allerdings sehr coole
sachen auf festgehalten ich kann jetzt
auf jeden fall schonmal kommunizieren
dass das buch wahrscheinlich sogar schon
im september rauskommen wenn ihr das
vorbestellen wollt oder so kann man das
bestimmt schon befinden aber das werde
ich nochmal alles mögliche videos sagen
ich werde ich aber man kriegt
zukünftigen videos bilder von der buch
arbeit einblenden und dann würde ich
sagen wenn ich den blog der schnitt wird
letztlich wurde aber gefallen hat würde
ich mich über eine bewertung freuen und
wir sehen uns in einem nächsten video
wieder